well I'm really glad that I could be the
first to welcome you to jsom EU I
pretend that all my talks are Keynotes
so
um you may recognize me probably uh as
the guy with the weird avatar on Twitter
who makes stupid jokes and occasionally
is an about node security you
may also be wondering uh why do you look
like this with the crazy beard why do
you look like a crazed
Lumberjack and uh I I actually tweeted
about this uh I brought my beard trimmer
uh but I forgot that things are 240
volts in Europe not 120 volts and my
battery was dead so I tweeted this now
I've realized at this point probably
looking for sympathy on Twitter is not
the best idea but still my hopes were up
and this is literally the only reply
that I
got so uh so before I talk about
computers or JavaScript uh I want to
talk about phones actually want to talk
about phones uh so I would like to draw
to your uh draw your attention to the
phone in your pocket right now so
probably you've got like an iPhone or an
Android but even if you don't have one
of those it's basically a supercomputer
right this thing in your pocket has more
computing power probably than what we
use to put a man on the moon and this
super computer in your pocket is
connected to This Global Network right
so I can get on a plane in the United
States with my supercomputer in my
pocket I can fly to Germany and when I
land assuming that I want to pay AT&T
through the nose I can still continue to
receive text message text messages and
calls that's pretty impressive so I want
you to think about you know I'm here in
Germany I I might go out to a bar with
some of you maybe we're hanging out and
let's say after a couple drinks some
good conversation I decide that I want
to stay in touch with you I want to I
want to keep talking to you uh by the
way this is the image that you get when
you Google for having fun in a bar
so if I want to stay in touch with you
what do I do I think bizarrely and and
wonderfully the thing that I do is I ask
you for your phone number I ask you for
this string of unique numbers that
identify you to This Global
Communication System right your phone
number and you might well you probably
never thought about why we have phone
numbers and why these things are still
around and uh it turns out it's because
of the disease measles let me explain uh
I've also uh gone ahead and translated
uh this disease this really won't make
sense if you are not familiar with what
measles is and I realiz it's not a very
common English word uh measles is
basically a terrible terrible disease uh
so you can do a Google image search for
having fun in a bar I would not
recommend that you do a Google image
search for measles it's
disgusting um so let me explain what
measles has to do with phone numbers so
uh a brief a brief history of the phone
number if you will so uh this gentleman
is Alexander granell so Alexander
granell was the first person in the
entire history of the universe to make a
phone call now he did not need a phone
number because he possessed the only two
phones in existence and these were W
wired directly together uh as you can
imagine this would not scale for very
long so what they
invented was a telephone exchange uh and
that along with the telephone exchange
came the job of the phone operator so if
you're sitting at home and you want to
call someone you would pick up your
phone and the light would come on down
at the at the exchange at the central
office and and the way that this worked
at First was you would ask for the Party
by name right because it's a central
office for a small little town there
weren't actually that many people um but
but look at this board there's a lot of
freaking plugs to plug in right and as
the phone system got more and more
popular it became more and more arduous
when someone asked for someone by name
to figure out where on this board to
patch these two cables into um you this
is the 1870s there's no computers to
help you quickly look this up right you
have to basically go to a booklet and
look up where how these how to patch
these things and what you ended up
needing was a team of very experienced
and heavily trained operators so it was
actually during a measles epidemic that
there was a physician by the name of Dr
Moses gy Parker and he was worried that
if
there was a measles outbreak you can see
that these phone operators are working
in very close proximity to one another
and measles is very contagious he
worried that if there was a measles
outbreak it could totally the
the the Telecommunications
infrastructure primitive as it was at
that time so he thought it would be
easier if there was a measles outbreak
to train replacement phone operators If
instead of asking for someone by their
name you simply asked for their number
and the operator could quickly patch
these two things together
so I I just want to reiterate here you
enter a phone number into your iPhone
because someone was afraid of measles in
the 1870s this technology these
decisions that we make and have
repercussions long long after we make
them so uh despite phone numbers
increasing the efficiency of the human
operators the process was still very
slow uh and quite expensive so for
longdistance calls uh this is back in
like the even into the 192 20s for
longdistance calls you would need to
talk to a different operator at every
exchange that your call passed through
because there would basically be
different hierarchies of of uh of these
exchanges so the average time between
you picking up the phone to call someone
long distance and actually hearing their
voice on the other end was 15 minutes so
you had to be really dedicated to
whoever you were going to call to to
spend 15 minutes essentially on hold and
they didn't have cool U jazz music to
put on while you're waiting either so it
need to be really important call now in
the early 1900s uh automatic exchanges
began to replace human operators uh so
in theory we could have replaced the
phone number at this time but the phone
system of course was extremely
widespread and you couldn't just rip out
the infrastructure and replace it
wholesale it just would have been too
expensive and too uh and too much of a
disruption so we had to gradually
transition the infrastructure from these
human operators over to this automated
system and and of course uh it was much
easier for for the for the Primitive
machines at that time to deal with phone
numbers and that's what people were used
to people were used to picking up the
phone and entering a phone number they
didn't want to have to learn some new
way to use the automated system they
just wanted the old thing to keep
working just
faster so if you think about the phone
in your pocket today it Bears very
little resemblance to a phone set that
someone would have used in the 1950s
right it's got a screen which they
didn't have back then it's probably a
high definition screen millions of
colors you can play freaking movies on
it um they photos with it and it can
travel with you wherever you go so the
underlying infrastructure the actual
implementation details of how we have
this insane global telecommunications
network is radically different and
radically more complex than a human
operator sitting in a booth manually
plugging patching two uh two circuits
with a cable and yet here we are in 2013
and the way that I call you is I punch
in a series of numbers on my phone and
this unique numeric identifier was
invented when the threat of a measles
outbreak was something that you actually
had to worry about in your
business despite all of this this is
still the most popular option for when I
want to hold up a little box to my head
and hear someone else's Voice come out
on the other side in theory we could
have replaced the phone number at any
time but technology uh there's I think
there's a lesson to be learned here
which is that uh technology unless it's
orders of magnitude better than what we
have really needs to interoperate with
the last generation you can't just
replace it wholesale right uh 100 years
later more than 100 years the phone
number has evolved certainly but it
hasn't been
replaced so one thing one way that you
might look at this I think is to say
that the phone number is kind of like
the universal UI of our
telecommunication system wherever I
travel in the world no matter what
country no matter what phone I'm using I
know that if I punch in a series of
numbers I can talk to someone on the
other side and I think that's pretty
cool now I think there's something else
like this that we have that I'd like to
draw an analogy to and that is the
URL so what we consider to be the
original web browser was written by Sir
Tim burner Lee on a next computer in
1990 but but even then the idea of
hypertext these linked documents was it
was hard
new uh in fact the term hypertext these
linked documents was coined all the way
back in 1963 by the uh gentleman by the
name of Ted Nelson uh are there any
angularjs fans in the audience can you
raise your hand okay Ted Nelson also
coined the term
transclusion I guess you can't win them
all
uh all right uh but even in 1963 50
years ago this doesn't even begin to do
justice to the age uh sorry to do
justice to the age of this
idea so uh Ted Nelson's work is an
extension of vanar Bush's concept of the
memx you may have heard of this this is
the kind of prototypical pre hypertex
system actually used uh it's a it's a
port manau of memory and index and this
is basically a it wasn't a real thing it
was a description of a system for
organizing all of your documents so the
idea is you could store all your books
all your other communication you could
organize and retrieve them radically but
it was pre-electronic so it used micro
fish um but what one thing I want to do
is take a second to reflect on the fact
that all of these things are systems for
storing and navigating documents sir Tim
Berle sir Tim burner Le's worldwide web
Nelson's hypertext Bush's MX uh these
are all things for viewing documents and
yet every year thousands of us gather at
JS comps around the world to discuss a
Turin complete programming language that
Rose to prominence thanks to being the
only programming language available in
the browser so if we started off as a
document viewer how did we get to where
we are
today well the thing I want to talk
about next is two clever
hacks uh and the first hack is the
notion of the cookie when the browser
was originated it was a simply a vehicle
for delivering documents it was by
Design HTTP as a protocol was stateless
but then the cookie allowed us to layer
State on top
so before everyone would always see the
same document no matter who they were
but cookies really changed everything
you could now tailor a custom document
based on who was making the request and
and I think ironically by introducing
State over to what onto what was
previously a stateless protocol this was
the key to letting the browser uh
transform into sort of application from
a pure document viewer into a sort of
application runtime and this I think
really is what leted US begin to give
native applications to run for their
money it was what allowed us to build
the first very primitive web
applications so the second hack is
realizing that instead of the browser
being purely a a document viewer you
could treat it as a viewport uh you
could treat it as a viewport to an
application running on the server a
so-called Thin Client so the data lived
on the server the application logic
lived on the server uh even deciding
what the user saw you would render all
the HTML on the server
as far as the browser was concerned you
weren't changing it right you were still
just looking at a document but this
document was generated dynamically on a
computer miles and miles away so
remember at this point there was no
JavaScript every time the user
interacted with a page by clicking a
link or clicking a button the browser
would transmit that command to the
server and the server would update the
state of the application for the user
and then send back an entirely new HTML
page uh and that represented the new
state of the application on the server
if someone else made a change before you
had requested new data you were none the
wiser the the user was none the wiser
once it was rendered in the browser that
was it so the analogy I like to use to
this model I like to use for this model
is it's kind of like being at a at a
club with a strobe light going on right
uh you can see what's going around you
but you kind of only get bursts of the
state at any given time everything's
really choppy uh your eye can only see
the world one slice at a time uh instead
of being this kind of smooth continuous
spectrum of movement movement or kind of
like a Zoot Trope if you remember the
old animation systems if those will
start to slow down they would look very
very choppy now the thing that I want to
emphasize here it's important to
understand that despite large parts of
the global economy being built on this
very architecture at the end of the day
it's a hack it's a it's a beautiful
wonderful hack I'm not using it in the
pejorative sense here but it's still a
hack I'm using the word hack more like
in Apollo 13 when the NASA Engineers
figured out how to mver these Square CO2
scrubbers into the round sockets of the
lunar module right it was this mixture
of awe and Delight oh my God that's
amazing but maybe we shouldn't attempt
this again in the future if we have the
option but there is an unintended side
effect that fell out of cajoling the
document viewer into an application
viewer and that strength I and that that
side effect I think is what ended up
being the strength of the web uh this
this is the thing that allowed web apps
to win out over their native
counterparts
and I'm referring of course to the URL
so in order for a browser to act as a
viewport onto an application running on
the server you need to tell the server
which view which part of the app the
user is looking at at the moment so in
order for someone to build a server
rendered web application the URL is
quite literally the first thing you have
to understand H the first thing you have
to think about if there's no URL there's
no
application uh but there's more to URLs
than than just this principle right uh
there's more than just sharing there's
more than the fact that I can just copy
and paste a URL to you and you can see
the same thing um so so basically by
sheer coincidence and though it was very
crude web applications were really the
first collaborative applications that
saw widespread use you was kind of
accidentally collaborative because the
data was all stored on the server and
you had these URLs that you could share
uh but you could also uh bookmark you
could also bookmark these things and
save them later uh to this day there are
some preference pains in Microsoft Word
that I've seen only once and was never
able to conjure
again uh and one thing I think that we
missed too is that web applications are
forkable if I'm in the middle of a task
and I see something in the application
that I'm like I should really pick up on
that in a second once I'm done with this
thing I can work on that thing in
parallel just by on my Mac command
clicking that link and it opens up in a
new tab that's crazy uh this allows you
to very efficiently ceue up stuff to
work on while you're without being
distracted from whatever your current
goal goal is and something that we rely
on every day on the web and to the best
of my knowledge is a feature that I've
never seen in a native application
that's
huge so this is all well and good serers
side rendered web applications have got
us very far uh and they have shown us
the importance of the URL but server
rendered applications have uh problems
as well the two most important problems
with server rendered applications in my
opinion uh one they require a round trip
to the server every time part the UI
needs to be updated so if you're offline
you're screwed if you're on a very high
latency connection you're going to be
frustrated and uh most importantly they
require the server to rebuild the client
state every time a request comes in so
uh for simple applications this is of
course fine but if you're trying to
build sophisticated app sophisticated
uis it's both uh complex and it's
difficult to cache and you really want
to cach it because they have to roundt
trip it every time so uh we needed some
kind of programming language that would
let us run logic closer to the user and
For Better or Worse what we ended up
with is
Javascript so uh especially at a time
when uh the average internet connection
was very high latency JavaScript gave
users immediate feedback with things
like form validations right you wouldn't
have to wait for this round trip to the
server you would just give feedback
right away um but at the time JavaScript
was very slow and very limited you
couldn't write entire applications on it
so what we started doing is just
slapping JavaScript on top of the server
rendered applications where it made
sense so this is a little bit like uh
bolting a rocket launcher onto a minivan
but at the time it was really the best
that we could
do but as we got a better and better
grasp on building web applications we
started butting up against javascript's
limitations uh we saw the benefits of
being able to do Ajax replacement on
some things we saw applications like
Google Maps which were just like
mind-blowing you remember the first time
you saw Google Maps you're like holy
crap I didn't know the browser could do
that so we started demanding more out of
JavaScript and in fits and starts the
browser vendors started to give us what
we were asking for and uh and we've
started using more and more JavaScript
in our apps which I think is really
great uh but now I think we're a little
at a little bit of a Crossroads so the
majority of web developers today in 2013
really really truly want to cling on to
the ancient hack for very good reasons
uh particularly it feels comfortable we
know how to use it it's familiar um but
it's not actually necessary anymore and
then there are other folks who see the
JavaScript future they've embraced it um
but they're they're kind of stepping
timidly into the future they're only
writing parts of the application in
JavaScript even though they might be
large Parts they're still still having
trouble getting rid of that original
hack of an
architecture um and and then there are
those who realize that the future is
here and they've started writing 100%
JavaScript apps which is awesome I think
that's great uh but the problem is both
users and pundits often decry these 100%
JavaScript apps they say they feel
broken or they're heavy or they're no
better than the flash dystopia that we
almost found ourselves in in the early
2000s um and I think the reason for this
is that in the same way that the phone
number is the universal UI of the phone
system so too is the URL the universal
uh UI of the web so with JavaScript
you're not required to think about URLs
first right you can write a Javascript
app without a URL and it will work just
fine but it will feel broken to your
users so if we want to step into the
future without breaking interoperability
with the past we have to somehow marry
these two ways of building applications
in a way that's cohesive and doesn't
introduce undo complexity into your
app so I want to ask a question of what
is a web app but the way I'd like to
frame this is by contrasting it and
asking what is a native app well if we
think about what differentiates someone
who's a native developer from someone
who's a web developer usually we think
about things like uh the native
development environments have things
like sockets that you can open uh you
can manually um uh manually manage your
memory you have 3D accelerated gra uh
Graphics you could do like 3D stuff you
have access to the local file system you
have concurrencies using threads or
green threads or fibers or something and
you also have numbers other than floats
which is pretty important for things um
but I'm here to be the bearer of bad
news it turns out that all of these
things are available in Evergreen
browsers today so you have websockets
you have typed arrays which gives you a
ton of stuff and it's basically the
thing that underpins uh what makes aam
JS possible webgl indexb file reader web
workers you have all of these tools
available to you so uh if you think ah I
program using HTML CSS JavaScript that's
what makes me a web
developer no sorry that's incorrect the
thing that makes you a web developer is
if you build apps that have URLs because
if you don't do that it's literally no
better than putting an Exe on an FTP
site for people to
download so how do we build applications
that respond and behave like native apps
but don't break the
web
um Malta said if I gave a talk about a
JavaScript MVC framework he would quote
kill me in my
sleep that's not a Verbatim quote um so
I'm going to introduce a new terminology
that I think is important for building
apps that that respect the uh URL so I
don't know how full of I am with
this but I'll call this R MVC for now
and the r stands for a router so if you
want to make client side applications in
the vein in the similar architecture to
how people are building native apps
which you really want if you want that
nice UI that you get on your native apps
you still need to respect uh the URL so
the router is an object that exists in
your application that is the single
source of truth about what's on page at
any given time and the router is
responsible for configuring the models
the views and the controllers based on
what the current URL is you can think of
it kind of like the serialized form of
your application you basically serialize
what's the current state of my
application you put it into the
URL and uh if any of those things change
if the model that's on screen changes or
the template that's being rendered
changes it's the responsibility of the
router to go into the URL and update
that uh and it turns out that the URLs
that we see in our everyday lives map
pretty nicely onto the MVC Concepts
right so URLs map nicely to MVC I don't
think that's much of a surprise so for
example uh in this first example SL
photos uh there's an implicit model here
right it's basically an implicit model
saying show me the photos template the
photos View and give me all of the
photos that you know about on the second
example we are identifying a model by ID
and it's responsibility of usually the
router to convert that ID3 into a blob
of Json or whatever and and we actually
uh I think just started working on this
in Earnest is how do we serialize
controller State into the URL and I
think the best place for this is the
query string I think that's what it's
designed for changes things like sorting
that's tends to be what I use
controllers for anyway um and you can
even do deeply nested things so you
might say show me the comment with the
ID of 42 that belongs to the parent uh
photo with an ID of three so uh so we do
a lot of this stuff uh built in in Ember
which is what I work on um but I'm not
going to talk about today instead what I
want to talk about is the two micro
libraries that we've extracted from
Ember that you can use in your
applications whether you're using
angular backbone whatever uh these are
basically very very small very modular
libraries that we've extracted out and
these form the underpinnings of the
Ember router but you can take them and
use them in your application however
you'd like so I'll just uh real briefly
give you a tour of the
API basically you create a new router
you say V router equals new router then
we have implemented this DSL on top so
so you say router. map and this will
pass you a match function and the API
just looks like this you can uh the
syntax supports Dynamic segments so
anything where you see colon ID here
that's basically a placeholder for the
ID of the model that you want to extract
and then you map it to a Handler so
these are just unique names that you
select and you'll see on the next slide
how these come into play so in this
example we're saying uh we want to match
a post slid we want to match all of the
posts if someone comes into that and we
also want to give the user the ability
to create a new post so once once you've
defined all of the routes in your router
the next step is to give it some
handlers so this is a very very simple
interface basically your router has a
method called uh get Handler that gets
called with the name of the thing of the
route that matches and then we invoke
that Handler for you and there are a
couple different phased things here and
I'll get in just a second into that uh
but basically this is broken into two
steps the first step for that for that
route is we say uh give me the model
that you want to represent so uh here on
line one it's saying app.st doind pr. ID
so this is some model library that I'm
using it's just saying deserialize that
ID that's in the URL into an actual
JavaScript object and then that that uh
model is going to be passed to the setup
function of the whole of the uh to the
setup function of the Handler and at
that point it's your responsibility you
can do whatever you want here you can
render a template you can update the Dom
whatever um so this is an example of two
of these things just a little bit closer
together so you can see how they map so
in this case we say match post slid to
show poost so what that means is that
when the user comes into slost SL1 for
example it's going to invoke the show
poost Handler and the model Hook is
going to get a prams hash and you can
use that post ID to show to basically go
fetch this Json from the server and
what's really cool is if you notice what
I'm doing here uh the model hook can
return a promise so a lot of libraries I
know there's been a lot of great talks
about promises here uh this anything
that you return it's a promise will wait
until that promise resolves to to call
the setup function which means that you
don't need to worry about whether the
data is there or not you just don't
render your template for example until
that data is resolved so this integrates
through promises very nicely with
basically any data management library
that you that returns
promises um so there's a lot more in
router.js uh and the other pair U the
other pair Library called route
recognizer we have really deep promise
supports the whole thing is instrumented
for promises we've been doing a lot of
work about Pro with promises and we're
very excited about them we also support
things like asynchronous trans positions
which end up being very important if
you're doing authentication in your
Javascript app we support deeply nested
URLs basically arbitrarily deeply and a
lot more so check out the uh the read me
I think this is really the secret sauce
in Ember the thing that people really
love and now you guys can use it in your
applications today so check it out we're
on GitHub github.com
router.js
um
so so a few weeks ago I wrote a blog
post called Progressive enhancement is
dead I really you can see that I
definitely do not have a penchant for
controversial blog and inflammatory blog
post name titles um I said don't be
ashamed to build 100% JavaScript
applications and uh the thing that I
want to reiterate is that the browser is
not HTML CSS and JavaScript the browser
is a box of content with a URL at the
top in the same way that the phone
system is no longer some person sitting
in the central office but I still punch
phone numbers into my phone uh it's
going to be the same with the URL for
the next 20 or 30 years you can imagine
HTML CSS these all get replaced with
webgl or some fancy widge Library the
point is uh the URL and the box of
content below it is what you are
building uh I was actually really
dismayed recently by uh I was using a
chrome packaged app which basically runs
an HTML CSS Javascript app in your
browser but it removes the URL I was
literally using an app in my browser and
I saw option to open it in my browser
what the is going on
here
anyway uh so I want to amend my original
statement don't be ashamed to build 100%
JavaScript applications but if you do
make sure that you do so with an
understanding and respect for what gives
the web its strength thank
you awesome thank you
Tom
anyone have any
questions food trucks in Portland I'm
sure we could cover that maybe oh
yes well thanks for the presentation I
see the main problem with this approach
is um is the URLs with the crawlability
of search engines like uh we're we're
doing 100% JavaScript applications but
we're to uh serve the search engines
we're rendering things with Phantom on
the server yes and that's that's the
kind of approaches are there any
developments you're aware of within
search Eng developers or yeah that's so
that's a great question so the question
is how how do you do how do you deal
with search engine crawlability using
100% JavaScript applications and I I
have a couple answers to that so I'll
try to keep it short the first is uh per
a Google engineer who I talked to who
will remain nameless it is quote
that Google has not started
indexing JavaScript applications so far
which I agree with but sadly is outside
my control uh the second thing is that
in Ember anyway uh we use handlebars
templates and it's pretty easy to plug
handlebars templates into your backhand
server and render them uh so discourse
is a good example of this uh if you guys
are not familiar uh discourse is an
open- Source GPL uh Forum software built
using Ember and Ruby on Rails and they
just do a very uh small rendering of the
content and put it inside of a no script
tag which is actually awesome for two
reasons one it's crawlable by search
engines uh two it's usable by people if
they turn off JavaScript in their
browser so I think I think we'll get
some really good solutions to this in
the next couple years but right now
there are some some hacks that you can
do to get around this
problem all right cool uh looks like
we're at of time but thank you so much
uh you can find uh Tom later on the boat
or also on Tinder so um feel free to ask
him any questions you want thank you Tom
Dale